[Music]
since I became your
Chancellor we have grown considerably as
a
country it is time to show America and
the
world precisely what we are
worth Madam Chancellor cour brought you
back you're here because you are nobody
you are not anybody and that means I can
trust you yes
[Music]
Chief you will never be in control of
this place ever again
um he's not dangerous is he everything's
fine the joh could be more pleased and
we like it when she's pleased don't
they yeah we
do have some pride let me do my work and
be grateful okay okay sorry without her
nothing makes sense you do have a
wonderful way with halfs don't
you yeah I'd like to see her is she
expecting you I'm her husband is she
expecting you one expects their husband
to enter a
room when I became your Chancellor I did
so with a heavy
heart but just know you fill me with all
the love I'll ever
need
and so I bless you all and I bless our
love
[Music]
always